now following criticism here in germany
of the pace of the coronavirus
vaccination rollout
a health ministry official has revealed
that berlin has struck preliminary deals
for an extra 50 million vaccine doses in
the summer
outside what's been negotiated by the eu
december was the deadliest month of the
pandemic so far in germany and the
number of daily deaths remains high
reaching a new record on friday pressure
is high to
protect vulnerable groups by quickly
rolling out vaccines but some
predictions in german media say
if the pace of inoculation continues as
it is now
herd immunity would not be reached until
2027
a quick temperature check and then the
shipment is good to go
here in eastern germany more doses of
pfizer biontex coronavirus vaccine are
arriving by the day
they're just some of the 600 000 doses
that are reaching vaccination centers
throughout the country on friday
but that hasn't silenced critics of the
german government's handling of the
vaccine rollout
too little vaccine confusing
registration processes
and a slow vaccination timetable the
list of complaints is long
but the german government is standing by
its program
and at this vaccination center in
western germany recipients say
the wait was worth it for me it's like
winning the lottery
my children didn't allow me to leave the
house i had to stay at home all the time
so it's great being among the first ones
to get the shot
despite the bumpy roll out there could
be some relief in sight
with a deal inked to secure millions of
new doses of vaccine
and the possible approval of a third
vaccine by month's end the eu is taking
steps it hopes will silence the critics
of its vaccine roll
out we're joined now by peter kramzner
professor of tropical medicine at the
renowned university
of tubingen in southwest germany
professor thank you so much for joining
us here on dw
with all these glitches in germany's
vaccine rollout could it
really take years to reach hurt immunity
in the country
well that is a bit of a sad news and i
do not believe that
however if we speak of herd immunity we
really
mean good immunity that would imply
also a protection against infection and
we cannot
say a lot about this so probably we
need the infection itself to have such a
protection
or we need lightly better vaccines to
reach herd immunity
but one other way is to protect against
kobe 19 the disease itself and
especially the more severe forms of the
disease
and that is possible with the currently
used vaccines and
i'm very hopeful that this will take
place and also very soon
there's been a lot of debate of course
about delaying the second dose of covet
19 vaccine
so more people can receive the first
dose earlier
is that a good idea
well there is some flexibility usually
as doctors
we have to adhere to what is approved
by the regulatory authorities and thus
yeah use the package insert and follow
what is in there so if it's four weeks
time difference between
first and second vaccination you should
be four weeks
however on a daily basis also here in
our travel medicine department for
instance
we are very flexible artistic so to say
we always use other schedules because
the people they do not come back
exactly four weeks after the first shot
they come
back eight weeks later some even two
years later
and we nevertheless of course vaccinate
them and we know
that this is not harmful in terms of
immunogenicity in terms of antibody
production for instance
it's rather better if you get a shot a
bit later
however as we do not know how long the
protection will
take after a first shot it is
better to adhere to the schedule but
whenever possible
a bit of a delay is certainly not the
problem i would be very flexible
yeah bottom line is i imagine that
medical community is not going to go
outside of what the clinical trials
actually showed you in other words what
the evidence is
professor peter kremzner of tubingen
university
thank you so much for your time thank
you
now breaker of covert 19 has prompted
chinese officials to tell people in two
cities south of beijing
to stay at home for seven days the
cities in hebei
province have tightened lockdown
measures including a ban
on public transportation nearly 350
people have tested positive so far
around 3 000 medical staff have been
mobilized to support
mass testing of more than 11 million
people china says it'll provide
coronavirus vaccines
free of charge
now we're joined by fabian kretschmer a
journalist in china and currently
in wuhan fabian china has sealed off two
cities following covet 19 or cover 19
outbreaks leaving 20 million people
under strict lockdown
how great is the fear that the virus
will spread
i mean also here in rohan you see that
more and more people are wearing masks
again and
that there are more temperature checks
and qr code registrations
needed when you enter shops for example
however it's still quite remarkable that
life
goes on as normal i'm just coming from a
very crowded shopping mall um yesterday
i was at a
very crowded craft beer place and i mean
it's it's basically um
live as normal here but there's an
underlying fear that there might be a
second
wave of covet definitely yeah well china
is going to provide covert 19 vaccines
free of charge tell us more about the
vaccination plan in the country
yeah up to now there are already nine
million doses that have been
administered that's actually quite a
large number and until chinese new year
that's
in one month um around 50 million people
are supposed to be vaccinated by then
however i mean with a massive population
of 1.4 billion people
the relative number is still quite small
however the chinese vaccines they have
one um
advantage that they can be stored just
in a normal fridge so the logistics is
actually quite
easier especially when they're also
exported to developing countries
now fabian china has confirmed that the
world
health organization will visit wuhan to
investigate the origins of
of the covet 19 uh pandemic what can we
expect
uh when can we expect that to get
underway
well there are mixed uh signals for
example the health commission here in
beijing today said we are very welcoming
we are just waiting for the
who investigation um to start
however the wh oh they say that um the
visas have not been granted yet and so
we don't actually know
when this will start and the wh o is
quite disappointed
by the behavior of the chinese
government that's remarkable because
in the past they were quite yeah
understanding um towards
beijing um you can say that beijing is
very afraid of
this issue getting politicized however
they themselves politicize
the question of the origin of the virus
really heavily for example here in wuhan
and there's an um exhibition about the
origin and the
the story how it's told here is really a
heroic story of the communist party
winning the fight against the virus and
there's really no room for
admitting mistakes or self-reflection
fabian in wuhan china thanks for that
update
well the uk has recorded its highest
number of daily deaths from the
coronavirus since the start of the
pandemic
with a new variant that appears to be
more transmissible
surging across the country authorities
are particularly alarmed by the
situation in london
mayor sadie khan says the virus is quote
out of control in the capital
and hospitals are facing breaking point
well we're joined now by our london
correspondent biaget
mass hi berget now britain's national
health
service says it's made plans to
vaccinate all frontline staff against
covert 19
in the next few weeks how realistic is
that though
well hundreds of thousands of people are
being vaccinated so we know the latest
figures are that in the last week
over 300 000 people were vaccinated so
the vaccination program here in the uk
is seen
as a success however when it comes to
vaccination of frontline staff of
doctors and nurses
there are many critics and they say that
the government has not systematically
prioritized frontline staff that there
was an ad hoc approach it was
said at the end of last year yes they
should come first but then that was
taken back
and doctors and nurses have really
implored the government to
to put them first because if if they
can't go to work if they
are are sick or they have to be uh
isolating then
that is really hindering the whole um
vaccination effort and
and obviously putting enormous strain
much more strain on on the
uk health service that's already
particularly in london
really bursting so they welcome this new
approach
and and and hopefully we will see um
that this is really in the next week's
um
being made happen well indeed there is a
lot of pressure uh particularly as you
said in london now the the mayor there
sadly khan says the situation in the
city
in the city is quote out of control
berger can you describe the atmosphere
in the city at the moment
i have to say it's very very quiet i'm
really living in the center of london
the streets are very quiet
the restaurants bars are obviously
closed only essential shops like
supermarkets and pharmacies
are open i hear the sound of sirens much
much more now it
reminds me of in the first wave i live
near
a very big uh hospital and you do hear
the sirens of the ambulance cars
uh in the days and also in the night so
that is something an eerie reminder of
of the
the crisis um critics are saying
government critics are saying that
it's actually not enough and there are
many doctors also are saying that
this even though it does seem to be
quite quiet
that we need even more measures so
nurseries for example are open
people are allowed to go to some
religious gatherings and
that they that they're saying with this
new virus being so
extremely transmissible that there needs
to be even more of a change of behavior
and people really do need to stay home
even more
all right well beargate maths in london
thanks for that update
this isn't a waiting room it's the
treatment room for kovitz patients at
the hospital in kailicha
one patient calls out to us to tell us
she'd been sitting and waiting for three
days
waiting for a bed to become free next
door these one are
too weak to sit on a chair so we put
them on the
on the stretcher
has been working here for nine years and
this pandemic is pushing him to his
limits
a third of his colleagues here have
already had the virus
how do you feel to see your hospital
that whole sometimes you feel powerless
because you don't have enough
space sometimes we don't have
enough oxygen point we need to improvise
and see how you can split
one point into two to give oxygen
sometimes you have to choose
two do you give first the oxygen and we
should wait
that that sometimes is very stressful
on average one person with covet dies in
the hospital
every day there's a small room next door
with somewhat better beds for acute
patients waiting for an intensive care
bed
at another hospital
the local health minister admits that
not everyone can get an icu bet
most are already full if the person
qualifies
for the icu defense to remember
even even prior profits for icu entry
there's always a scoring index
the house is on fire so this is actually
the waiting all the waiting area of the
hospitals where people would normally
wait for their treatment but you can see
it
people who come here with
non-covet-related issues emergencies
are for now being treated here because
they need the space on the other side of
the building
for potential covet cases south africa
meanwhile has reintroduced tougher
lockdown measures
there's a stricter mask requirement
alcohol sales are banned
and beaches have been closed but police
are overwhelmed with enforcing the rules
only patients over the age of 45 are now
being tested at the state clinics
the demand is overwhelming
here in virologist wolfgang price's
laboratory
every seconds test is positive the peak
of the second wave is expected in south
africa in mid-january but even after
that
experts anticipate further waves
i fear that neither the current enormous
surge that we are experiencing now
nor the arrival of a vaccine sometime
into halfway through 2021 for a
small proportion of the population will
be able to make a big difference
the government announced it is already
in talks with vaccine manufacturers
but there are no details yet
back in kailicha however there is hope
initial studies show that
during the first wave up to 40 percent
of residents were already infected
and possibly even immune social
distancing remains impossible for many
here
dr mukonkola and his team are therefore
still bracing for a tough few weeks
ahead of them as the cold wave sweeps
through delhi
and the sun disappears for days behind
the thick fog
it is those without a home who suffer
the most
according to estimates about 150 000
people in delhi are homeless
making them particularly vulnerable to
the city's extreme climate
as the cold days give way to chillier
nights
the homeless queue outside
government-run shelters for respite
fifty-two-year-old pramot seni is a
migrant laborer living in delhi for the
past
twenty years the corvette 19 lockdown
left him unemployed and without the
resources to rent even shared
accommodation
he ended up on the streets
we cannot do without shelters when it's
cold
during the summer i can sleep in the
park with just a sheet
because at least there's a cool breeze
in the winter it becomes very difficult
while sani has been a frequent visitor
to such shelters for the past few years
this year he says the situation is
different
everyone has been instructed to wear
masks inside shelters
maintain distance and clean their hands
as often
as they can the pandemic has posed a
challenge for the authorities and civil
society organizations alike
as it is not just the cold they have to
protect people against
during the summer we could arrange for
people to sleep in open spaces like
parks to maintain social distancing but
during the winter we have to protect
them
both from the virus and from this
extreme cold
according to delhi government officials
the capacity to house the homeless of
the city in the shelters has been
reduced from close to 18
000 to less than half of it to maintain
social distancing
to make up for that temporary shelters
have also been set up in different parts
of the city
apart from taking other precautions in
these shelters like conducting thermal
screening
and providing masks and sanitizers
isolation wards have also been created
to accommodate those who show symptoms
many social workers
say that sometimes it gets difficult to
explain the seriousness of the pandemic
as it is the basic day-to-day survival
that takes
utmost priority for the people who end
up in these shelters
for which they are forced to step out in
crowded areas to seek work
dr sanjay kumar who has been working for
the rights of the homeless for decades
has the same concerns he says the
government needs to do
much more this
we need to maintain more social
distancing among them
and encourage the use of sanitizers
because once this spreads among the
homeless it will get very hard to
control it
it will go beyond our control because we
won't even be able to trace the chain of
contact
sani says that everybody tries to take
precautions as instructed by the shelter
caretakers but it is not
easy nobody can have a mask on for 24
hours
people do take them off at times or get
together to just chat with each other
but it should be fine as long as we
maintain some distance
the coming month will be tough for those
on the streets as the cold peaks
and will drive many more seeking a warm
bed and a blanket to shelters
but for people like ceni the hard
reality is that surviving the cold at
the moment
is a bigger concern than surviving the
virus
celebrating christmas eve for the around
2 million orthodox christians in germany
it's something of a challenge during
covet lockdown
take the serbian orthodox church of
saint sava
in dusseldorf a year ago thousands of
believers came here to worship
then they didn't have to register but
now the church needs to be able to
contact them if a coronavirus outbreak
occurs
this time only a few dozen worshipers
can take part in the service outside
and a similar number inside the church
[Music]
we have to keep the people safe none of
us may be infected in the church
we have to take care of each other
social distancing face masks no hugging
nor any kissing of the icons as is
common practice in orthodox churches
it's important that we abide by the laws
of the state
at the same time we have to do what god
expects of us
and that is to take care of each other
and to show love to one another
and to be considerate
the choir has also been reduced to just
a few singers
the faithful show their understanding
for the security measures
[Music]
unfortunately this is what we are living
with now we have to make the best of it
but we still have to come here and pray
the custom on christmas eve includes
lighting the so-called bagnak
an oak tree it's a reminder of the fire
that warmth the place where christ was
born
but the authorities have forbidden that
this year too at least the faithful are
allowed to light candles to commemorate
the dead
and to pray for the health of their
families
it's certainly a different christmas eve
this year but some of the traditions
have survived
let's take a look at other developments
in the pandemic
the united states has set another daily
record for new infections
with almost three hundred thousand new
cases and more than
three thousand six hundred deaths
reported on friday
australia's third largest city of
brisbane has entered a three-day
lockdown
after the emergence of a variant first
detected in britain
officials say it was contracted by a
cleaner at a quarantine facility
no community transmissions have been
reported
a new study published in the lancet
medical journal says most people
hospitalized with coronavirus
still have symptoms after six months the
most common ones are fatigue and muscle
weakness
but also sleeping difficulties
you